笠松は釣り社長です a
アイスバケツサイズベース管財も
というかもちんのイベントの1つとしてアイスバディチャレンジレーマ
いつも流行っています
今僕のところにもいろんな方
ビートボクサー daichi さんや
東海親がいろんな方がそれいろんな人がいますいろんな人がまあ特に
アイスバケツされちゃってくださいこ
てくれてるわけなんですけど
梵天ちょっと今回は
止めておきますマウスだけですよ本当にみんなには申し訳ないです
そんな弓は分からずにやってる人が多い気がします
塔頭水素の水かぶりの方っていうか俺もやろうという気持ちでやっている人が多いので
やっぱり
来週は血縁者を選択できるんですよ
募金するか
水かぶるかとシエンタ口があるので
僕は損壊ねアイスボディサイズはちょっと
それだしたまあ嫌なんで
持つと5人させていただきます
募金できで振込先は5をしっかり日本 als 協会出版社の方頭のほうですねそちら
に振り込み席があるので
また動画の説明欄でのせずオープンです
ぜひ
にできる方はしてほしいなとか思っています
レンズぼかして今回できないんですけどお金の方を使うさせていただきます
コイル募金者と叩き言ったら失礼だと言われるか一応
募金するか持っていますんで
違うんだよねー
あまり好きじゃない pr
像桜1万円振り込ませて頂きましたん
なぜ辞めたかっていうと
第二はないんですよ
ん
いかんだろうなぁん
個人的にはやっぱは市場キッスぞ
[音楽]
voodoo
ちょっと桃とかですね後ろ多分声が来ないんでわからなくても
強気の嫁れると思うんです
湿気もだいたいバケツチャレンジわー
パッキンです別
それコメディでも何かしらにしろとか
様のことを誰かの歳出の正
すごいいいと思うん
ねまあ
は違うありません
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
目立った
[音楽]